all right
so we are about to discuss the design of
our efforts at computational
bibliographic citations so for people
who are in the twitch universe
you're basically eavesdropping on a
working meeting working on design of
features for often language this
particular feature is one that I have
not yet seen that's been developed by
don't know exactly who developed this
but I suspect there in this meeting and
we're about to learn about it okay so
the question is we've had it we have a
number of places in our knowledge base
where we have references for example
this seems to be Einstein on the present
state of the radiation problem okay but
it's a mess cuz it says physique site I
don't even know what's I mean site
schriften or something it's a list what
physical okay um okay so the question is
how do we how should we compute ibly
represent those references is that does
that be + what we're addressing here
yeah okay and so what you're proposing
with MIT that said entity physical
constant what oh you cheated there what
this what what's the so the first one is
can the main decision to be made like
the molecule is it an entity or is it
function
I kind of think this is a function
because I think what's gonna happen is
that we're going to want to do so for
example we have the notion of a okay
well let's start off with what I mean
okay a DOI is like a URL and a DOI is
equivalent to what we have here correct
although there are actually a few cases
where the same document has multiple
DUIs it is not most to happen but it
does actually happen yes and not every
document outer does have a dear way
obviously I mean has anybody gone back
and given do eyes to things from 1913 no
probably not
no Vejle has done it completely a couple
of publishers have gone a hundred
percent back yeah but what about the
publishers that are no longer in
business
for instance Devils not done right I
mean clearly a publisher from the 1600s
who isn't in business anymore who's
gonna put dear eyes on that who would
consider themselves responsible for
putting deer eyes on that
for instance JSTOR DUI on many many odd
things okay
no it's always always that's incorrect
that's all you think wait no JSTOR
somebody else okay but just JSTOR also
have an ID for their things yes which is
distinct from the DOI yes so what we've
got here we've got deer eyes we've got
JSTOR IDs there comes a list father
boned okay I think well I think JSTOR is
the source of some of the duplicated do
is because they didn't go back and
double-check that there wasn't 31 and
their contents in some cases duplicates
content on other sites like some of the
American math Society yes yeah okay so
the typical thing you might want to do
here so for example I just did in fact
just just did last night a bibliographic
study about mr. Darcy Thompson where I
was looking at so this was by year I was
looking at more by decade I was looking
at the
and I just happened to have this on my
screen I was looking at the frequency of
words and abstracts right so I don't
know how that would be related I mean
here for example it would be good
wouldn't it to be able to get the actual
title of the paper and things the
complete bibliographic not just the
citation but the complete bibliographic
information here don't you think
that can can store that I mean just like
with the thing I was looking at previant
here
it had let's see what what did it have
it had the the fields and it was a mess
right so this was some you know this is
some titles here right the fields here
were look at all these messy titles with
incorrect capitalization and so on but
the fields were you know these they're
probably it's probably a double encorage
type thing I would guess I don't know um
title author's corporate authors etc
right so this is this is some kind of
ontology um what is average per year
oh no that's different well who knows um
is this are you recognizing what this is
is this some standard thing that I'm
looking at here
anybody I would not know but it is not
here today okay all right well anyway
but but so what is your comment on my
statement that we actually want the
complete bibliographic citation which
includes author you know if you if you
look farther down my comment is yes and
no I mean there are a couple times 10 to
the 8th of them so it will be not
realistic to have them all and many of
them
I understand but we also need the
possibility to have them in this form
and we need the possibility to go from
the complete one to the abbreviated one
right I understand and to reformat them
for different styles yes exactly so I
mean we've had for like at least 15
years maybe 20 we've had these various
libtech importers and things and that
correct yep
what does how does that work I don't
even know what it imports into um so if
I look up well that's not impressive
okay citation management I don't know oh
this is EndNote hello somebody is not on
mute and should be
hello somebody is not on mute I think
it's a PR team
somebody's not on mute
you
somebody is not on mute
that's better now it sounds like okay
no not better that's not working um
I think we know who it is I just got a
ping
that's not allowed to happen we these
meetings have to be if we're going to do
this live like this we kind of have to
have it so that it's not distracted
right
um
otherwise we don't get to do this okay
how does this work
this endnote thing
you
you
is that better yes maybe I think so yep
no back and forth
I'm gonna go on mute to hear myself for
me yeah I passed a note along to let's
see if we can improve on this
you
all right
some let's try to go back to this
alright so how does this work what what
does in what format does this generate
citations um
okay so we seem to have some technical
problem here
so we've got a lot of background noise
we need to solve the technical problem
before we go on
you
um
now we should not call it background
noise it was clearly cut off so somebody
has to mute and I'm hopefully that's not
cutting off the rest of the sound
okay all right okay so in what form does
and I think we just lost Stephen to firm
Network drop out someone have to see
them get back in hello
yep you're back
okay okay you hearing me again okay so
what's the answer to how this works with
bib tech somebody answer that for me
he made the citation insertion no I mean
what is the format that it uses right so
it's got
rip tech of course has its own format
right no no no I'm asking what fields
does it have we have an association here
that represents so it should be an
association that represents the
different elements of a citation usually
too much on this one that's really not
representative if you go follow down in
notebook okay but I'm asking the
question does somebody know what bib
tech does no you mean that does it do it
like an association or does it know like
some other much simpler question I'm
just asking what are the fields that it
supports so does it support arbitrary
fields it will support arbitrary feels
but you know it there's a certain
vanilla set of fields and publishers all
define what feels they care about okay
fine but so I mean if I look here at
what it says it has it has some kind of
author title publisher etc etcetera
etcetera thing is that correct
yes I think it has some default fields
and if you add more typically the styles
using these we'll ignore them I see okay
fine fine I understand so it's not
really it's just an empty container so
to speak yes it's more the styles using
it that defines what they expect and
they ignore the rest okay all right
let's so let me let me scroll down here
so that I'm not so I'm actually
understanding what you guys talking
about okay so what are you showing here
you're showing examples of where we use
this stuff is that right did not uniform
and we would greatly benefit by being
uniform okay fine okay so you're just
showing bad examples basically not bad
just takes a lot the world doesn't do it
uniform no I understand okay so what's
this this is a currency like with
respect to alpha needs like this our
currency our sources that we have in the
knowledge base
I see wow I didn't know those were
entities
and so what are the properties of those
entities I didn't know we have those
abilities this is the back end of
microsourcing it alpha hmm I didn't know
this store yeah well these are attached
to individual individual properties so
it is just property level sourcing in
alpha this is this is how they are
represented okay
well that's useful that's good what is
this doing here
okay all right so I see this is your
list here do eyes archive reference
numbers URLs okay okay
but the wiki data items are not the same
type of thing the discussions with Ellen
and we might want to have a way to point
one of them
I understand but we've we've talked
about an external reference mechanism
for a long time right that is analogous
to URL but is our own and what are we
doing right now if we have an entity and
you want to find its Wikipedia
representation how do we do that do we
have a mechanism for that now
you're breaking up heavily there's
there's a way you can access that ID but
it is not documented or or promoted in
any way that's it's that's a related
thing that we should talk about when we
figure out what we want to do with this
and I I had been thinking that if we had
some kind of reference I guess this is a
function that's a different thing but if
we had some kind of a reference object
that's how we would want to represent
those things want to come back you fire
a particular
along let's look at what we had talked
previously talked about I think we had
discussed some time ago external let's
see yeah external reference does anybody
know whether we have notes on that
I think there's a sort of a rest page
future eyes somewhere that's that's
about the extent of it should we look
for that um okay but but the idea I
think was what was it called external
reference
oh yeah look at that what do you know
okay represents an external reference
from a given source with a given name
external reference evaluates to entity
when the entity is known in the language
was our concept
possibly or or we would use two entity
for that
right that would also be reasonable um
but so you know this concept of an
external reference seems like a good
concept because some of these places I
mean to me
the modern URL scheme is not that
different from an old-fashioned you know
phys Rev let you know 3875 whatever it's
what I'm saying that's a URL as well in
a sense URI as well Michael do you think
that's a correct interpretation
I think so so in effect and they're all
a bit hierarchical like they you know
it's a journal you know a journal of
volume a year I mean the volume in year
there's redundancy in the case of you
know there's built-in redundancy from
the volume and years stuff but ok but so
then if if what we're planning is some
kind of external reference and I don't
know whether that's the right name but
um you know right now if I have a random
entity like I say I don't know um let's
say tungsten or something all right can
I get the wiki can I get what that is in
Wikipedia Wikipedia capital e lower n
capital IB Wikipedia en ID e n like that
like I said these are these are not
exposed it's just lowercase n just ideal
English Wikipedia yeah like that
well that was unimpressive are you sure
it's that's the right name yes
kept not capital in yes I mean that's
that's the right that's the right thing
that works now it's like I said it's not
promoted it's not what it should be if
we're gonna expose and promote that
anywhere yeah right I understand
but so oh yeah there we go so what is
that ID number that's the that's the ID
for that Wikipedia page you can have it
you do Wikipedia data of page ID goes to
that and you would get that page there's
a there's I can never remember offhand
what the what the URL syntax is but
there's a there's a Wikipedia URL that
you you can use that ID number instead
of a page title there's also that it
seems to me that an external reference
concept is a good idea and you know this
is really the only problem is that there
is a more general version of external
reference which could be some kind of
weird you know
objection an external program type thing
which is an even which I don't think is
really the same kind of thing
this is an external fixed you know
external identifier more than an
external reference perhaps am I making
sense
in this case you have the entity
different from the external identifier
to Wikipedia or something when it comes
to a book or an article the two things
seem to be mixed so would we have an
entity for a book and a reference to the
book itself something that I say so the
question is the sort of ontological
question is is Moby Dick and a reference
like if we say page 75 of Moby Dick
whatever that even means given that
there are many editions and so on but
let's imagine let's take that as an
example okay page 75 of Moby Dick and
then we ask the question what well okay
is Moby Dick like a URL merely like a
piece of a URL or is Moby Dick an entity
in itself exception right so I think the
analogy of that for journal citations
would be you know I would imagine I
don't know if we have this but I would
think like physical review physical
review is probably just taking a long
time to do this it doesn't know what it
is that's really weird do we not have
these I thought we had journal serials
um as an entity type we do why doesn't
it physical role because it's physical
review ABCD okay so so that will be an
example that's an entity write physical
review letters make sense yes um and
I think um so just like presumably
moby-dick is an entity which is that
book so my claim would be that the sub
indexing that's really strange why would
we not know what that was
assuming Moby Dick is a novel oh is this
the default because we have famous text
as a separate thing from book and so
that that's probably the default
assuming for that one okay well um we
should fix it yeah okay um okay sure um
should perhaps external identifier take
the entity and return a link to that
entity or something uh I'm sorry go
ahead what what should okay so the
problem is that we need to sub case in
here so for example one thing we could
imagine that there's an entity Wikipedia
and then were sub casing to page IDs and
so on just like you know at the top of
this you know hierarchy for books the
top of the hierarchy is the book you
know is the book name so to speak right
there isn't whereas for a journal there
sub casing into phys Rev letters you
know volume such-and-such page
such-and-such
am I making sense yeah so you know
there's an anchoring entity it's some
kind of concept and then there's sub
casing into that and then there are
things like the do eyes and so on which
are in a sense their own so an argument
would be that one could say something
like external
I mean a possibility would be something
like external identifier and then one
could actually say fizz red letters and
then one would be saying I mean let's
say for example the main source is
reserved letters and then there's the
sub sources you know then there's an
association which gives the sub
information here is that obviously
stupid it's not stupid but I don't know
why you vote wanted them for what
purposes okay um let's just make a thing
here um I think I see the reverse
direction is much more important than
the interesting one okay which is what
given that you're I give me a convenient
and nice way to get all the fields okay
well hold on a second so what you're
saying here is given what is this okay
so this is flipping it around the other
way so this is the second argument here
is the base basically and then this is
the sub identification okay is that what
we do that that is what we're doing now
for URL right yes right which is nice
that you can go and open it okay yeah
okay so this is the sub referencing
thing okay yeah that's a good that's a
good concept that we need some sub
referencing mechanism okay features of
references okay if a DOI and we have a
nice convenient way to get active data
to do something with okay and this is
using what is work information what does
that mean oh that's information about
the work yeah with that DOI and where is
this going what is cross rough course f
is one of the keepers of two isolated
okay so they have a public API
is that right yeah yeah so if I would
look at what is I could see so I'm
taking that and this is a request to
that dear to that service to give me
that DOI okay and so I'm getting a bunch
of information there cool
okay but it's not canonicalized so we
would have to this is uncooked service
you know connected service right
you guys at all in some sense Indians
naughty novels no I understand but in in
our sense like okay I mean the dates we
haven't turned URL into URLs and we
certainly haven't turned communications
of the ACM which is surely an entity for
us right but everything that comes back
from
crossref is also surely not an entity
but all the ISSN numbered journals
should be entities in so far as it has
journals that have ISS ends we should
have you know entities for them if I'm
not mistaken correct
I don't know complete it is no added a
lot of journals somewhat recently but I
don't think we've got ok fine but in
principle in worst case we could imagine
a journal that is merely specified by
Isis an if all else failed
which is another one that he's
parametrized you know things with a base
that is Isis an is the base just as DOI
is a base
to represent a parameterised entity kind
of thing I think
okay making references from data
um
you
you
okay let's see
so here
okay given a reference we want to create
a DOI is that correct
you guys there or did you lose me yeah
sometimes if you have some old stuff you
know can you you have old cable that
have it in old-style diptych
okay and so the other issue is given a
yeah this is a nice thing given given
being able to generate citations in a
certain order and there you know people
whether their whole business is
basically maintaining databases of
citations and putting them out in
different formats right okay but now
what about okay so this is an importing
bib tech okay so this is this bib tech
format and you're saying can we import
that right now do we have a mechanism
for importing that right now I don't
think so well this is not necessarily
big tech this is the big item that in
which you're fully free to put whatever
you want there I will be translated as
it is into the paper okay so look seems
to me that what we want is first thing
we want is this notion of external
identifier which seems like it's a it's
a constant feature across a bunch of
these places and that would be analogous
to you know URI Universal whatever
resource identifier right this is our
this is a version of that that is a
variety of different forms of external
identifier does that make sense
okay so then what we've got is we've got
somehow the base of the external
identifier and we've got its detail does
that make sense so for example that base
could be
you know I mean there are a variety of
different kinds of things that could be
a Wikipedia
Paige ID
maybe
tell us some number here
what what else I mean or specify a
language right well so in fact this base
object here really should be an entity
typically that could be you know um that
could be an entity of type you know
let's see identify a system effectively
is what it comes down to so what are
examples of identifier systems um so in
example would be a DUI a
Wikipedia
page ID Wikipedia in language X page ID
right um another identifier system and I
think you already had some of these up
above what URL another one is all kid
another one could be pubchem ID etc etc
etc that correct
okay so then these for a DOI does that
do eyes different pieces have a you know
have a meaning there
you
I think it's very flexible and up to the
publisher okay so another thing that
could be here is an ISBN or obviously
the do the components do have a meaning
you
right
and that's a that's a so these base
identifier systems okay so one question
is either the base or the what work can
we call this this is actually the
identifier itself
so consult a hero go ahead you can pick
any arbitrary wiki data page for example
and it's going to have a list of
identifier associated with that thing
mapping out into other various systems
okay I just just to look at some other
examples yeah okay well how do I get to
one of those I just got a wiki data look
up Barack Obama
why do I go here search
tungsten chemical elements
okay okay
you
so anybody put some hour
yeah
now
and this will be very confusing to look
for us on this page but okay but anyway
so these are these are typical things
these will be typical types of of
identifier systems right
and each one of these could then be um
so if there is a notion of an identifier
system and one of these might be
whatever there was there's one here
called zvg number then for example that
identifier system as an entity can have
various properties
chants I think a lot of you are on mute
because we're having so many of those
audio problems you know if if you have a
reasonable audio setup why don't you get
off mute so we can actually tell who's
agreeing or disagreeing um
are you thinking of these only for a
bibliography or something more general
no I'm thinking of it for any place
where we have to have an external
reference an external weigh a thing that
is not part of our knowledge bases
identification system and what you are
describing here seems to be a
quintessential case of that which is
these journals where where the bastes in
effect is you know where the base okay
is a basically a journal I know here
that okay so the other case would be is
a book a possible base you know
certainly an encyclopedia for example
might be a possible base that's making
sense to people yes because this list of
bases is potentially very very large if
you're for instance in an preprint
series of Institute's there are
thousands of Institute if they're only
print serious so what it's an identifier
system if it's got you know MIT you know
lab for computer science report such and
such why not
because we must maintain the list of
properties for each identifier well if
they don't have very many properties
they don't have very many properties I
mean of minimal properties will be I
understand it the more properties it has
the happier it is but we don't have to
have properties for all of these things
potential interfaces to get to objects
themselves that's correct if the objects
can be called potentially what sir maybe
a lot of work to maintain this for
thousands well fine but I mean we don't
have to start with thousands we're
looking at a small number here I mean
what we want an extensible system
because if somebody comes up with
another you know another identifying
system we don't want to not be able to
do it because whoops we only designed
for three of them or something I don't
understand how book is a base though I
thought the idea of the base is the
scheme that includes books right yeah
well I think that's a weird case which
is why I put it in brackets okay in
other words encyclopedia is a valid base
because there are fairly few
encyclopedias in the world
right
see what I'm saying I mean in other
words if it was some but books you know
they're uh whatever it is 20 million or
something of these things and so that's
a little bit more bizarre so the
question is when you want to refer to a
book in your scheme for references over
here when you do books after your eyes
no ringer has your eyes for every
chapter chapter oh that's crazy weird no
it's very convenient we can very point
it because they also say by chapter so
it's very sensible okay so wait a minute
so then okay so there can be do I by
chapter so that that right there tells
us that my scheme of having a base an
identifier isn't completely stupid even
for a book that is you know in a book
like I was giving the moby-dick example
page 77 whatever that means and whatever
Edition it is right see what I'm saying
but it would then fall under do I not on
the book if it is a DOI
yes but I'm saying I'm saying the
question is look what we're saying here
is that the base here I mean what's
what's awkward about this is okay this
base is the concept of a URL not a
specific URL what we're really seeing
here is that there's a multi-level thing
so what we end up with is external
identifier what we could end up with is
something like where the where the
entity type entity of the identifier
system is booked then the actual
identifier however that's represented
here is Moby Dick for example and then
where there's a sub entity here which
says you know some kind of you know page
77 or something that makes sense but
this would need concretely they are
published by whom then to know what page
77 otherwise makes no sense yet I agree
but now how do we represent
a book so I mean a typical way that we
would represent a book that's what's it
what's a good book that um here's a good
book table saw and Edition hopefully
that book exists as an entity okay so
there and what is our canonical
representation of that book that's kind
of lame so that's clearly a non
extensible representation there and but
that has various properties right well
it is it clear that we need the basis to
be validated so that users can only use
those bases that we have in advance or
rather they could perhaps instead they
could have these in a way that they can
write whatever they want I just a
simpler solution I've got a simpler
solution there's no reason why this base
so one of the type yaaaaa this is the
right way to do it look if we have
external identifier the the what most
typical base will be an identifier
system right but that doesn't need to be
the base the base could be a book entity
or a journal entity see what I'm saying
so if we have external identifier here
then what we can have is indeed our
physical review letters right there
right which is a periodical and then
it's actual identifier is whatever the
you know volume page whatever did that
make sense again yes but I feel like the
DOI is much better but may be better but
that's okay that's a different external
identifier what's your point I mean that
this is there's no guarantee that as we
know there is not a unique external
identifier for a given object right as
you've said even even among do eyes that
can be duplicates and what I'm saying is
that given you know you can have
multiple external identifiers and you
might want a way of of you know coercing
them transforming them
into for example you might say what is
the DOI of this right so potentially
what you want there is maybe I don't
know um you know something like external
identifier of entity you know blah blah
blah blah blah do I effectively is the
thing there and then another external
identifier here and that will be the way
of casting that first the first textile
identifier into a DOI external
identifier if that's possible making
sense just like we would potentially
have entity of external identifier if we
have an entity that corresponds to the
external identifier what do you what
about things that have civil web
presence how would they be represented
well what's an example random Frenchman
or from 1805 that has not been digitized
okay where you're saying there is no we
don't know the base URL for the thing
court there is no currently okay okay so
that's an issue of how to deal with so
for that what you're telling me is that
the there is no entity that can go here
the only thing we could put there is
something which says well okay so then I
think what I think I think the best we
could do will be to have an entity
identifier system of well just journal
for example and then the actual payload
would contain the journal name such as
we know it right and that's the best we
could do
now I'm not completely happy with the
asymmetry between I mean in this case
here we're putting this in I mean it
might be better to instead have
something where we say
[Music]
and we say something where the whole
thing is an association um we're we're
saying something like bass is and then
it's an entity or bass is something like
um yeah and then and then we have to
have certain see the problem is that
there's gonna be a template if we know
it's a journal right then we know it has
certain things in it right so it no we
know it has certain fields that make
sense
yeah if we know it's a book okay so you
know you know given given the type of
identifier system being used there are
certain fields and go ahead
the one thing that somehow still various
mister following well then we know the
external base we know a lot about the
sink if you don't know the external base
we know nothing about the sink we do not
even know it is a paper or something
like this well then what can we how can
we cite it in any way I mean if we're if
we know nothing about it then we know
nothing and there's nothing to say what
do we know
I mean in other words we gotta have
something that we start with otherwise
there's nothing to say right I thought
but perhaps precisely we need a
reference in which we put all we know
and then a function that looks for the
possible external identifier of that
thing okay in the books of papers of
Leibniz whatever there's some piece of
paper now they're published okay I've
noticed mostly or no letters little
letters but yeah letters between
scientists which surely are republished
you know I elected works and such but
what's how do you refer to them yeah
I'll show you a beautiful example yeah
right here I've got right there there's
a there's a page how do you refer to
that exact question okay so the answer
to that is that is in some archive
somewhere it's in a physical archive yes
okay so that's okay so then we've got
this notion of physical archives and
actually somebody just gave me a thing
what is it called some maybe the
Stanford libraries or something somebody
is trying to make up a standardized
format for that um gosh what is it um I
don't remember but that's a you know
that is a perfectly reasonable case as a
physical archive yeah I mean look I
think that what that should be then is
just like we have a base that is a
journal where we know it's a journal
right we don't know anything else but we
know it's a journal so then a possible
other base here would be a you know a
physical archive and then given that
it's a physical archive you know people
have various ways to refer to them I
mean for instance you know that the sad
fact is when you actually get into the
archive it's in boxes it's usually in
some very obscure place it's you know
it's often quotes off-site of wherever
you're going and it's in you know it's
and maybe there you would have I mean
like if you look at I don't know the
British Museum's information on them
let's take a look I mean if we look I'm
pretty sure um
I mean I've looked at these let's say um
let's go to British Library search the
catalogue so if we say if it will even
get me there everything in the catalogue
okay so let's say Ada Lovelace um then
okay so let's say so these are books it
looks like right
okay somebody is breathing into the
phone but anyway the um so how did they
reference this book so they have first
that's that's just there okay doc equals
British Library I bet that's an
accession number of some kind
but it that aaron is not here today
because he would know all the stuff um
but and see notes and tags
that's not relevant details ah there we
go look at this UI n bol whatever that's
there that's some
I identify a system number whatever I
make sense
missing sorry like the original idea if
you have a reference it's pretty clear
what the references in the center
probably some kind of piece of paper or
a bunch of pieces of paper there's some
information on it but now as an external
identifier I feel like it could be any
kind of physical artifact in the museum
and in our current scheme I don't have a
certainty a prokinetic way to determine
if it's a reference also than a physical
artifact yeah right and it could be look
it could be an IOT device that's sitting
you know on in a in a in a turtle nest
or something you know and it happens to
be um who knows I mean yes that's right
but that's the point is to have a system
where we can deal with both the
references case that you're highlighting
here and the more general case but one
workflow for the reference case would be
I have a DOI and I would conveniently in
the front and make the equivalent of
make hyperlink which makes no sense for
general external identifier okay but the
DOI you know just saying the DOI doesn't
happen to have its prefixed URL stuff
but you want to make a link from it is
that right no this in the notebook to
the reference section at the end of the
notebook what like like a normal paper
in the main text you say see it f12 and
at the end of the notebook you have
references and there's 12 and I don't
want to manually type it I'm going to
automate this okay what does that have
to do with this I understand but
position only makes sense for something
that is a reference it doesn't make
sense for why I mean it could be as well
saying you know the the the random pot
dug up on you know in this place that
shows up that's in the British Museum
Oh Assyrians right yeah I mean I think
for example the type specimens or
biological species I don't exactly know
how those a reference does
anybody know that in other words there's
always a you know somewhere in some
Museum in some jaw is some horrifying
dead creature that is the type specimen
for such-and-such a species and well so
you're you're broadening this system
essentially I mean this project started
with the idea of just building
bibliographies around but what I'm
saying is um the I'm trying to find an
example of a type reference um type
specimen who knows okay but in a case
the you
I'm trying to do is put this in a more
general framework that we can reuse for
other things
yeah and that's fair right so maybe
maybe as long as it's a framework that
looks pretty clear the subset of that
framework that is most relevant to doing
references and Docs is what we would
return to - well I think so but I mean I
think we can get look we'd be meaning to
do this ice non-identified thing which
we already got tons of data for for wiki
and other things so this for example
there's a couple of different ways we
could do this we could say given an
external identifier what is the URL
associated with that or we could say you
know if there is a canonical URL we can
have that as a property there or
hyperlink or something making sense in
that way if there is a canonical URL for
it but there may not be a canonical URL
for example consider a book where there
is a version of it that's been scanned
and is on the web but there is also an
amazon catalog reference
so what I'm saying
yes sure they live in various different
ways right so given and by the way I
mean that that's another typical example
would be the Amazon catalogue will be
another typical thing that has IDs um
but here I think for books they they're
based on the ice PN aren't they
typically but then there's also I mean
in in the in the what are they called
UPC codes is another another example so
UPC codes are a mess
but that I don't they're everything they
cover anything and everything in
principle
in principle can I please sure but but
the UPC code for a can of beans from a
particular manufacturer I don't you know
there's it's a messy you know
on I mean look the other there are many
you know look we made that whole giant
poster of different term schemes like
this um
the
you
anyway so
but it but it sounds like we have to
support that or I'll allow for that to
be support right but so the issue here
is multiple you know multiple
destinations from an external identifier
I mean clearly you know we could
perfectly well have something but it's
gonna be it's mostly unique or not
with one of these things which is an
identifier system I would say mostly not
doable mostly
got it if the book has an ISBN it's
still in copyright and there probably
isn't a um you know there's not a
complete version of it on the web um but
okay but so let's go back let's loop
back to the stuff about references again
okay let's use that as an example to
understand this because I think I'm
sitting round about this more general
concept of external identifier so say
VIN numbers would be external
identifiers what numbers we are in for
course we have vehicle identification
you know why not I mean look Oh place
where you could go easily well there
might be I mean there's certainly
service connections that we can have to
places that will do that
IP addresses obviously we already have
but IP address we already have a notion
of an IP address or numbers would be
external references that's correct we
also have that notion which which we're
you know those those ones are really a
different story because those are ones
that we are supporting independently
right but we we have to agree that they
are a subset of what could be expressed
this way right so then what we've got to
do is we've got to have something where
if you say external identifier we might
need I mean that's you know it's not
canonical at this point you have an
external identifier where it entity the
identifier system is IP address right
and the payload is whatever the IP
address you know 1:40 dot 177 dot
whatever um um okay but that is got to
be equivalent to
you know something like IP address of
that raw string makes sense
yep now the fact that it isn't unique
well tough luck I mean none of these
things are unique right and the only
question is what are the translations
how do we get the translations and you
know to know whether you know the
identity question for two things you
know that you thought were the same
thing that's a really hard question and
ultimately it's going to be unanswerable
but it's also a little bit misleading -
if they're if the head is called
external identifier and not external
object then the identifiers as an equal
or not trivially the object identifier
the first who has a more different
equality structure the identifier as an
identifier can be equal or not but that
which it identifies might not be the
same exactly but I'm saying is currently
you can do a little bit I I agree that
this case is an awkward case because
this is a transformation of identifiers
in the space of identifies it's not
saying is the machine at the end of that
IP address the same machine I agree that
this is an awkward case right these are
these are essentially our what can I say
the the the slang or something for an
external identifier and in particular
cases but the same for the earlier one
like the paper itself is different from
the identifier of the paper yes but this
is an identifier what we are you know
the thing we are bouncing around here is
an identifier not the actual paper but
typically it fell to a paper if you
don't get filtered in and identify awful
for paper in the reference okay look
look let's to be to be completely
bizarre about it let's imagine the
external identifier represents the
program let's say a piece of Wolfram
language code right in that case unlike
the notion of a paper where at some
point there are a thousand printed
copies of it somewhere bits and hand it
to somebody right and that is clearly a
different thing there is an identifier
of the program and by the way this
relates to how the resource system works
because you know one possible external
identifier is our very own resource
system and that's a little weird but not
completely crazy right so so I'm my
claim is that these what we are doing
here is a calculus of identifiers not a
calculus of actual objects right in the
calculus of identifiers x' will contain
things like for example in the calculus
of identifies as the question of does
this identifier contain another
identifier yeah what else is there in
the calculus of identifies what else can
you ask but very understood you would
allow something like the first F let
example you're on the page to have one
of the string argument out source which
I don't sing the out sort of the paper
are the authors of the identifier okay
that's a different thing
that's the annotation okay you are right
that's an issue right so so there are
two things here there is the identifier
okay that's that is a good point I agree
there's a two entity grab the identifier
no but but but but there's another point
which is that there are things the
identifier is the main thing upon which
there can be sort of a calculus of
identifiers so for example well the
identify might not have a date the
identifier is merely an identifier but
the identifier given certain properties
okay so the basic point is the authors
and things like that are properties of
the identifier no I do not and if I
refuse to
yes I think we need a function that
takes NT fire and returns a reference
with all the information that can be
collected it couldn't identifier itself
or something more than IV I say just
saying I don't think it should be called
a reference but I think it should be
called it's doing the object but no that
stell object is something else different
thing that we want to do use but if
these are what I think it could be
blurry raffiq ruffles if we're dealing
with bibliographic references if that's
what we want to I mean if it's a VIN
then that's a quite different story you
know there is a car on a park
in this place um but I agree that that
if if what we have here you know we
could imagine something where what we're
dealing with is bibliographic or
citation or something bibliographic
citation of whatever and that would be
or alternatively just citation of well
citation data of the external identifier
would not be totally crazy thing to have
so that is asking of the external
identifier but then the question would
be then there's the question of how do
you um get the external identifier that
corresponds to a particular citation
given that you have the citation in your
hand or you're reading it in from
somewhere then what you'll want is
something which is essentially an
interpreter of I don't exactly know what
it is really here it's something some
kind of you know but this isn't quite
right what's I go ahead you know if you
put author name right like just a name
would it try to return a bunch of
possible identifiers well that's that's
something which okay so the next
question is in what are we storing this
demographic data if it's an entity store
then you can start querying the entity
store right and for something like that
crossref thing that you were showing
earlier well okay so is there a place
where you go ahead what what is your
thinking about how we actually store
this data because what what you're
saying is to make this interesting in a
sense we have to be storing both the
external identifiers which is just a big
bag of identifiers um and together with
all kinds of properties of those
external identifiers that are for
example specific author names and titles
so that interpreter can yes you know I
will put it in the other way so if this
reference object has all the information
that the user wants to have and one of
the fields is the identifier in case you
can access something related to that in
the internet then a collection of these
reference objects could be place at the
at the end
and not book and we can refer to
individual items I think said that but
sorry I missed that this concept could
you could you say again another yes I'm
thinking a bit of what could be done
with with BTech in the sense that you
have individual references in which you
put the information that you want to
have it doesn't have to link to anything
outside in the internet and then you can
put them at the end of a notebook
somehow and in the notebook you can say
if you click in this number one it goes
automatically to the first one of these
references
what do you mean like goes to I mean do
you mean Scrolls and output down to it
or pipe exact scrolling school that's a
little weird I mean that seems very
old-style
well yeah and you're saying that
self-contained a notebook and you know
we did exactly that when we developed
public on and we have the means to
probably extract a lot of that
functionality ok but so this is in
notebook this is a different thing in
notebook references right so what is the
modern world I mean if I'm starting to
write a paper this is an academic
document about about Smith's snails
reference in 1822 right and typically
that is a key to a bibliography that
you've maintained yourself maintained
for you right so there's two levels you
that's a key which goes to your local
bibliography which then goes out again
to the global bibliography of the world
I think my main point is having
information what you call local
bibliography allowing you to put every
bit of information you want to know book
I think what that should be is you
should have an entity store that you
maintain of your bibliographic database
which is what people tend to do right
which has so that I can go to my
bibliographic database in my personal
bibliographic database this is you know
Smith 0 1 5 7 or something right and you
know we did that but it what Jose is
describing
turned out to be useful too and we
provided that as an authoring tool where
you you click a citation insert and you
get a number of fields to fill out of
the information you typically want to
publish as part of your bibliography at
the end so this is a question of the UX
of whether you enter that information in
the middle of your document when you're
when you're thinking about it okay
that's a you access you though
well it isn't it isn't because that
information is then stored in your
notebook it's not necessarily required
to go out to a database because the
notebook itself can structure that and
still render it format it and make it
look good and then that can be recovered
as data by taking apart with those cells
right but that's a separate that's the
type of issue that we have of storing
you know that's what I can eyes and the
and the data set in notebook stuff does
is storing I mean I don't think we
should think about this way I think we
should think about it as think about the
entity store if it's a question of
locally caching the entity store within
a notebook locally saving it within a
notebook that's a separate issue yeah so
I'm saying so in other words you imagine
there's a global entity store which will
be what people will typically actually
want but you know and potentially but
maybe when they you know they might want
to peel off from their global entity
store a local entity store that can be
transported with the notebook I mean for
example when you're reading somebody's
paper on the web you can be indexing
into their global entity store which is
also in the cloud right it's only the
case where you send the person a
notebook that is a free-floating
you know document that where it has to
have all that data right in it okay but
I want to come back to this question
about so you know we've got one notion
which is this external identifier thing
but the other notion is where does the
annotation data that you know where does
the additional stuff that is in the form
of you know the author blah blah blah
blah blah I mean here you know again
this is actually more complicated
because really this is an author string
because there might actually be an
entity for the author right
and the office string is an uncommon
Achilles you know John B Smith yep right
um as opposed to author you know I don't
know what what Smith's we have I'm sure
we have a variety of Smith's here yeah
but you know you would also have to have
I mean that's good that entity because
we can provide a construct that's broken
down but you would want to offer author
first name middle name last name you
have to go into many detail all cat naam
references can be format at all
different ways with first name or last
name you know or not know right well so
that raises the question just like we
are talking about you know so I mean
look other constructs okay so just like
we've been talking about the phone
number case right well we have a I mean
things like phone numbers and human
identifiers basically you know person
what is we had a notion of this person
named personal person personal name or
something um where yes you can do all
those kinds of things you can have an
honorific you know you can have a you
can have a better they called suffix you
know like brain whatever the 17th or
whatever um you know and they might
style the suffix differently so right
might style it in Roman numerals some of
them might style it as a number um you
know there's a lot of detail here and we
have curated some of those kinds of
things like like the honorifics we've
curated I believe we've curated those
have we not Alan do you remember yeah
personal title we have well we have we
have abbreviations for things and we
have the expanded forms of them the full
the full name as a property of the thing
let's look up and the writers know
that's interesting we don't have that I
think that's a that's some kind of
degree title thingy we don't seem to
have it okay
interesting okay but in any case the you
know yes one could imagine something
like this that is an attempt to the
personal name identifier which will
never be unique you know unless we have
obviously and principal we've got you
know social security number and things
like that
which represents another one of these
external identifiers right but but you
know so again personal name is - another
one of these things that's full of
annotation full of non unique nice to
have but doesn't really identify
anything necessarily making sense
knowing somebody is called John Smith
doesn't tell you you know there are many
John Smith's in the world
and to nail it down you have to have all
sorts of you know you might or might not
be able to nail it down I mean that's
the that's the wonderful world of
medical records and things like that is
knowing whether the two things two
people are the same um but in any case I
mean of course in in the real world
sometimes people just want something
that other people will acknowledge to
other people that this is a valid
reference and I did my homework they
don't care if it resolved they just
wanted to have the right words with a
journal that people recognize and it has
to look correct and correctly formatted
so all the DS I know they do in the
entity world we want to do better but
that's not in general what people do in
the whole rest of the world no I
understand they just want something that
is printed on a page and where the
teacher can say yes you put the graphic
citations in or order an editor yeah
right
well that's night it's like that Tim
what was that song about you know copied
the the the love Chesky thing about you
know copied his his references from the
moscow phone directory yes Tom Lehrer
right yeah it's not Moscow I can't
remember where it is okay whatever
they um but any case but okay so I don't
think that's you know that is not what
we aspire to provide right I mean you
know I want to come back to what can we
compute it from something like this
right for example the number of pages we
can compute something well I don't know
what that page ID is that doesn't look
like a page number this may be wasn't it
a modern page number that's an article
number yeah right that's the article
number and that's the sequence yes then
the article
right so what's your point there I mean
so look there is okay so what you're
basically saying is that we could
potentially have something called just
like we're saying personal name we could
have bibliographic citation and it is
just a wrapper which is what you're
calling reference here and this is
coming back to essentially your design
from an hour ago or whatever it was
where it's essentially something like
this I don't know whether we can get
away with the word citation do you think
there's too many other well we might be
able to get away with the word citation
um item item that is extremely general
pretty mean site doubly graphic item
yeah well is it I mean what what is the
meaning of citation to cite something is
what what their difference between a
reference a source and a citation to a
librarian
I would like an errand to be here to
answer that one well and I like thinking
of the citation as what's in the
narrative whereas what's at the end of
the journal is itself not the citation
but what the citation alright again we
are we are down one librarian in this
discussion so we can't answer that here
but but let's imagine it's bibliographic
item okay then we've got all kinds of
different things we've got the journal
we've got the journal etc etcetera
etcetera and now in in this scheme that
we're discussing here the external
identifier of a bibliographic item might
be its DOI it might be some kind of
canonicalized version of journal volume
page that type of thing did that does
that make sense Michael oh it's so we
can choose the external identifier for
the journal case I mean back in the day
when I knew about this stuff um you know
there could be weird stuff like there
was a series sometimes it was like um
you know so it isn't quite like it's
pure volume and page unfortunately
but in a first approximation there could
be you know an external identifier which
which is a whose base is maybe it could
even be something like journal reference
is the base is the you know is a fuzzy
base not like DOI which is a nice clean
base but this could be a fuzzy base
where basically what then happens is you
have journal arrow and then an entity
here and so on I mean I think that will
be a way of dealing with this concept
where we are I think that's actually not
a totally stupid way to do it because
that way you know another version of
this would be a very clean external
identified DOI arrow and then the only
thing that's there is some kind of
number here am I making sense so in
other words we get in this case of this
external identifier is a pruned version
of the bibliographic citation right that
is attempting to be the identifier as
opposed to being the full bibliographic
item with or without you know for all
you know in the thermographic item there
could be a picture of the thing so I'm
saying I mean in the in the fields here
it could include page count it could
include you know abstract it could
include all kinds of stuff yep you know
including to fire itself absolutely it
can include the identifier um like DOI
if it's a specific identifier like that
right right and so this then just
becomes a repository a canonicalized
repository of the my graphic information
for which bibliographic item is a better
name I agree because that then I mean
bibliographic suggests that it is some
okay
unfortunately you know that there's also
this this thing here we might say we
might have to say something like type
and this is where it might get a little
messy right because this could be type
journal as opposed to type book and so
on or type you know because you can
imagine other things which are things
like you know type personal
communication which has completely
different fields associated with it you
know who's it from when was it etc by
making sense which suggests to me that
really what we wants to do is
bibliographic item really wants to
concentrate on things like journals
maybe books prints give or take so okay
but then but then are you but then then
what do you want the type to be so maybe
the type instead it's no John I think
that I've just drawn an article because
so the type is an article one what's the
difference between article and a you
know what's a blog post I mean this is a
narrative document of some kind
right as opposed to well a book or as
opposed to a personal communication
which is nothing or as opposed to a pot
in the British Museum or the type
specimen of a salamander
which again probably we shouldn't
probably you know the type specimen of
the salamander isn't a bibliographic
item I suspect we should restrict
ourselves because there is a very
definite notion you know right now well
you know you can refer to blog post you
can refer to Wikipedia articles in a
journal right yes okay so I mean look
there are fields that exist you know
when it was so this is the standard
stuff that for example on a resource
object right in resource objects we
actually have these fields do we not so
if I look at a a typical resource object
for okay let's take a look at the fields
that we already have here so yeah here
we go so these are typical source
metadata subset of the Dublin core
metadata standard all right so that
gives us some I mean again that's that's
its own weird thing I suspect if we try
and generalize bibliographic item too
much we're gonna wind up having it be
the same as everything else again and
that we should really restrict it but
I'm more curious what is the calculus of
bibliographic items so I'm saying
so what do we have we have containment
right it's something does something
contain something containment
overlapping blah blah blah
we have various measures of size do we
have you know we potentially have you
know same author
you know same attributes I same author
etc um we have clearly we have a date
you know we have date place things like
that those are presumably computable
things in many cases the date will have
complicated granularity you know
granularity might be the period of a
particular volume much versus in the
modern world people in self many many
different possible publication dates
okay okay so preprint date so how would
we deal with that emissions yeah burning
yeah but how do we specify that so if
does it have the same identifier it has
the same URL in archive for example you
know do you are any changes they
identify your stays yes they are V 1 V 2
V yeah okay so I mean for that we're
going to end up with some kind of
version arrow blah blah blah and if you
don't fill in the version you don't you
know it represents somehow all versions
ok specify the date in which they
accessed yes it's the most common one
right right I mean that's for a website
is the access date
because I just type into another
notebook that's turtle um okay so let's
let's loop back to what we can actually
implement okay so where are we here so
what we've got
I mean first thing is to do first thing
is the external identifier business
which we are I think in a position to do
Alan we already have a bunch of cases of
that right so we're this this is the
thing that we want to return when you
ask for we would have a property of an
entity that is extra things I would
think so external identify as we already
talked about that
right um no that would be a list of
external and identifier objects right
because they're all we specified with
what the external yeah so it could be
all kinds of different things and a
given you know a given thing might have
ten of those or something what's the
what's the way to query for the the
external identifier I think I think yes
but I think for the popular ones they
can be properties I mean in other words
there might be an obscure cross over
that there's an IMDB thing for some who
knows what you know I would say that for
a given thing you know for a movie
there's an IMDB ID right if there
happens to be an IMDB ID for other
people yes well I don't know is the
answer I mean we might Michael I mean
what would we do what would be another
way that what we have because this is an
extensible property thing for which
property attributes are the most common
way to do it this is essentially a
property instance okay and they could
they could be attributes and it could be
entity entity property type external
identifier I don't know
fire system goes to blah blah blah right
I think that the first step is us first
to just start putting in well okay so
the question is you know the other way
we could do this is to say external
identifier essentially external
identifier rules and to have this thing
on the right hand side be a list of you
know do I
goes to IMDB ID goes to goes to etc
right so that then we could have so that
would be a little bit better to find in
terms of hmm I mean well we could just
have these yeah the right hand side just
the ID partner it's still a full
external identifier I think it should be
it well yes I mean that's a mess isn't
it I mean so the other possibility is
that these are that every identifier
relevant to a given entity is a
top-level property of that entity it's
not obviously totally ridiculous
we could when we actually Josh and Ben
and Tony and I had discussed this a
little bit this morning why don't we
sketch out some specific cases of them
come back and try to pin down the design
okay all right so that's the external
identifier business um so the other
action item here is some the
bibliographic citation bibliographic
item okay so are we in a position so
what would we want for bibliographic
items so what we want is the you know
what we basically want is import plus
export are the two things we want so the
import would be you know read a journal
citation and put it in canonical form
in rich format is it available what do
you mean is it
what well I'm saying I'm saying let's
take well one of these bit items if it's
a thing basically yeah it's a strange
yes I yeah it would be a string it would
look like this it would look I mean it's
the typical stuff that I interpreters
eat okay then beef deck is already much
more organized because it has fields
sure fine okay but but that's that's
great
in that case we have an easier time
exactly um okay but I mean fundamentally
what this is going to be is interpreter
of interpreter of bibliographic item of
and then let's say you know John Smith
phys Rev let you know and we can allow
you know the fact that I don't have
periods and things like this the usual
stuff right do we already have um you
know you know anything okay is that it
does there exist there must exist in the
world stuff that does this I mean this
is a pausing project right to be able to
read something like that and to be able
to read the so is it the case that most
of these things are there JSON formats
and things like that for these things
are they're mostly just strings I think
the standard thing is to create huge
biftec files in which they each entry is
organized by fields already
when you say organized by fields is it
like a-you know a rows and columns type
thing or is it like each thing is just
says things like author equals I think
it I think I was seeing some of them in
other places here and it was table for
equals exactly or 31 exactly but I mean
something like this you know that's kind
of horrifying thing is presumably I
don't know whether we already have
pausing for that time that it's taking
but but that's an ISSN basically there
be an ISSN for that okay so I mean
that's it that's one of our challenges
is to parse those things good and any I
mean as I understand it any journal that
wants to get fourth class postage in the
US has to have a nice lesson so I
believe they really all do
Oh what about electronic journals do
they have eyes a sense yes they do
people like to get them but I don't I
think the ISIS ends are going out by the
post office aren't they or am I mistaken
about that I would have thought that's
Library of Congress no I ISBNs are given
out by Belka they have nothing to do
with Library of Congress really they're
they're a private organization that
gives them out so I assassin is let's
see who are we let's ask that is an
intergovernmental organization created
in 1976 great okay and that's a picture
of their building in Paris
okay so they they really exist there's
an identifier and the identifier is the
building at a 45 rue de whatever um okay
but it's also saying there uh um okay
so it's like I can I guess I mean let's
look at the one for the US well wait
wait a minute wait a minute I'm pretty
sure the post office has something to do
with it in the US but I might be wrong
oh I didn't work oh well okay but in any
case there is a notion of
canonicalization um in okay so one of
the things we need then is an
interpreter that goes that way and turns
it into something which is probably
similar the bib tech fields right except
for the boob tape feels as you were
saying before I'm welcome authorized
they're kind of what you feel like is
that correct yeah okay so then what we
need is export which is taking our
canonical form which will be a
bibliographic item blah blah blah blah
blah
um bibliographic item of blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah and we'll take
that and then I mean then there are then
the question is what we want to do is we
want to be able to say export string
bibliographic item bi whatever as what
is it APA style citation or something
does that make sense
yes and so that will then generate a
string which is well actually it might
not be a string because it might need to
be formatted in some way how would the
string be specified as formatted then
it's all boxes I guess okay so it might
be the argument it's an element so right
so this this could be a string or it
could be boxes you know or it could be
what would the thing we call formatted
or something um
well might be boxes but I don't really
like that name but anyway that that's so
that would then give so that takes this
citation and puts it in that form
okay and and then there might be some
centralized place where you can go to go
from okay so now there's external
services right and an external service
might be something that says well
actually we could have something like
given an external identifier but is a
DOI right DOI whatever number at the DOI
has then we should be able to look up
that as a bibliographic item so we might
want to do this might be an abuse but we
could potentially say bibliographic item
of that and that could use an external
service to try and populate the citation
information able to also keep this as it
is because it has all information that
you ever wanted where the reverses
non-trivial of course we could how to
populate it visit says no no but I'm
asking is how do you go the thing you
were showing me the crossref thing yeah
right of way up at the top somewhere
here where you have this thing where
you're calling um
where was it done yeah yeah where you're
calling crossref and where what it's
doing is it's returning what we should
be able to put into a bibliographic item
right but that's in Canada to do a
itself is good people coffee item I feel
like it's like expand normalized that's
a function that I put on top of it fine
but what this is doing is okay okay what
we want okay fair enough fair enough so
what we what we're trying to say is
really what this is is bibliographic
data of yes external identifier and then
there's a standard set of it of
bibliographic data which would be okay
so this is probably not what we want
here um okay so that the correct thing
is something more like this where
bibliographic data would then go use the
external service um to do this to
populate it that makes some sense there
okay so then this would return
potentially a bibliographic item could
return a bibliographic item I think yeah
um that has a bunch of information yeah
and then and then and then what you
would do here is you would say you know
full citation or something or whatever
it is or you could say you know full
citation kamar abstract or something
like this authors comma abstract um okay
so okay this seems I don't need to make
sense going back up to your export
string boxes maybe boxes would be sell
why it makes more sense um but I don't
know what yeah because there will be an
inline sell of some kind that is that
citation yes um
yeah I mean you know you could imagine
things with you know a formatted
hyperlink you could imagine as another
possibility
all kinds of different things here that
once we have this um so I mean the
computability the the interpreter then
the main thing it's gonna do is it's got
to recognize the journal ID it's got to
figure out what's the volume cuz people
are gonna write silly things like you
know in this there will be many variants
which we surely I mean this is a solved
problem citation you know pausing is
something people have talked about for
millions of years haven't they I mean
aren't there these all these some I
think they used to be services that did
that wasn't there a citation or
something I don't know what it was there
was something that did that years ago I
remember running into the CEO of that
company so if it's a solved problem
you're thinking it's a service we can
access it's a service we can access it's
the thing we can license it's a um it's
a library that just exists I don't know
I mean I remember that company I talked
to that CEO on a random at a random
conference probably 29 years ago I could
probably find out who it was and that
person had a small company that just did
I'm pretty sure it was just doing this
and I think maybe they sold themselves
to Thomson Reuters or something um
but again I think you know I'm surprised
heaven I mean haven't we encountered
this in the past being able to cuz
because then you know what we want to be
able to do is then to transform it into
whatever you know outperforming having
it as a data set so for example yeah
what we want here when we interpret it
yeah okay the interpreter is returning a
bibliographic item in all cases right
which we can if we want to bibliographic
item and the bibliographic item could be
a um the that bibliographic item then
has its own properties right yes I think
it should it should contain the
information which is in the string and
then some other function we'll try to
get from there the identifier yes I
understand but I mean for example this
could say data set and that could give a
data set that corresponds to that
bibliographic item right um
I mean it's also conceivable that we
could have that this could say you know
APA citation that's another possible way
that we could turn this into that we
could get out something like that as an
alternative right rather than this might
actually be better if there a limited
number of citation formats am I right
about APA is that right American
Psychological Association or something
is that a citation format yes um okay
all right I think we should are we do we
think we've come to reasonable
conclusions here yes okay all right time
to wrap this up so I don't know if
anybody has actually been eavesdropping
on all of this but if they have I hope
they found it interesting absolutely um
and take it from there who was who is
project managing here sorry I've
forgotten already
I've been H okay
all right great all right